okay everybody knows I'm a huge Star
Wars fan and that's why I wanted to
touch on this story so you may have
heard about this that in England right
now there are a hundred eighty thousand
people who identify as Jedi Knights yeah
that's right in the census under
religion they put other and they write
in Jedi Knight one hundred eighty
thousand people they believe in a faith
called Jedi ISM and let's get a little
explanation about what it is well what
do the Jedi actually believe how you
practice Jediism well it's a very
practices there's meditation there's
physical fitness there's a focus on
diplomacy and general etiquette you know
being nice opening doors that general
stuff
there's also focus on community service
pictures as far as religious beliefs
that varies from person to person if
you're looking for something in relation
to God or a deity a specific definition
of the force that does vary from Jedi to
Jedi all right frankly I would have
liked my Jedi representative to be a
little more well-spoken a little more
confident but okay that's fine he's
doing all right almost everything I
learned is from the Star Wars movie this
basically is my mantra no try not you do
not there is no try yeah that's right
Yoda taught me everything I know okay so
what I think is interesting about this
is if the basic mantra of us is be good
to man you know be socially conscious
all the good stuff let's remove the
lightsabers for a second is this not a
religion I mean what qualifies as a
religion it's great it's a life
philosophy and if you live by this life
philosophy you're gonna be a happier
person and there's power in that you
know the power of positive thinking it's
a popular notion now you know why not
whatever whatever floats your boat and
if they're getting out there and they're
being good to people and they're not
killing in the name of Jediism they're
not conquering other nations in the name
of Jediism they're not denying people
reproductive rights in the name of
judaism why not you know let people let
people be good to each other and
identify with with what they want if
they're in fact
being good to each other the key here is
kindness alright I've got another Jedi
condors out here yeah are you on board
absolutely look I wish I was still a
virgin and Kelleen in my parents
basement
but that's not my reality I don't know
that that's one of the tenants
necessarily no it definitely helps yeah
I'll live in their parents basement yeah
I I think that sure why not I mean it's
it's very it's very in right now to do
like cosplay right I'm gonna saying that
course but yeah I thought originally
that was just dressing up like Bill
Cosby but no type of cosplay and I was
so embarrassed I wore a big cable knit
sweater for Halloween I'm like look I'm
cosplay and they were like that's wrong
I had a jello thing yeah I was it was it
was embarrassing yeah uh but I I do
think that like what Beth said if sure
if you believe in something that's
basically just don't be a douche right I
think that should be you know that's
that's the religion for example I have a
almost three-year-old kid and people
like her how are you raising him you
know cuz I'm Jewish my husband's
Catholic I'm like we're raising him
don't be a douche douche don't be a
douche ISM can I can I do cura ism yes
gonna do a new car sir you said it now
boom done
please follow me don't be a douche dokdo
biddies my twitter handle is don't be a
douche yeah I have to do that I know as
part of this though that it won't gain
certain amount of traction cuz when you
look at those pictures and you know
you've got the guy in the robe and he's
stopping the car or the people which I
mean so it's just based in fantasy but
at the same time everything in religion
I mean Moses parting the Red Sea
sounds like a Jedi force trick or that
really happened that's the one that
happened that really happened yeah or
everyone's coming back from the dead all
that stuff so do you need some of that
mythology actually does that actually
help the cause to have some stuff that
really isn't real that helps the
religious maybe because you have to have
faith in order to believe it you know so
it's the same it's the same kind of
notion but if you follow the basic
tenants then you're going to be a good
person and you're going to have success
in this life because if what you put out
there comes back to you and that's
basically what this is what this is
saying you can't make fun of people for
that I'll let you finish this hang you
could make it your own religion let you
bring you home now you can't Google
image Jesus walking on water but you can
google you can google up you can watch
it's real
it really happened that's funny have it
on celluloid that's actually really
funny cuz you know really just people
always want to go back to the Bible and
quote this or that or that this now all
you have to do is oh we'll go to youtube
and remember when you go to said door
later and yeah that's it three hundred
years from now people will be looking
back at the Star Wars footage like see
is really happened I'll be using it they
are brother and sister how could it ruin
it for everybody
Oh